bonjour merci d'être avec son sur rt
france ont évidemment c'est un véritable
choc pour la ville de nice ce matin
c'est un choc mais c'est un choc mais
aussi de la colère de la colère on est à
la deuxième attaque terroriste islamiste
a nice on est à la troisième
décapitations dans notre pays jusqu'à
quand jusqu'à quand ça suffit voilà
maintenant il faut qu'on agisse vraiment
moi j'ai envie de dire à monsieur macro
et monsieur darmana rester à paris resté
à paris c'est plus la peine de venir
nous voir
on avait déjà eu valls était venu nous
voir quand on a eu 86 morts sur la
promenade des anglais où aller on avait
déjà eu hollande qui était venu le voir
ce n'est pas nous voir plutôt vous
rester à paris et fait quelque chose
voilà voilà faites quelque chose parce
que maintenant ça suffit ça suffit il
faut pas s'arrêter nous ce qui se passe
là en ce moment au moment où on parle
autour mais j'ai tué vos amis c'est ce
que les forces de l'ordre sont sur le
pied de guerre on le rappelle
l'assaillant a été interpellé peu de
temps après les faits quelle est
l'ambiance autour de vous
comment réagissent les autorités sur
place je suis vous voyez la basilique
notre dame derrière moi il faut savoir
qu'à basilique notre dame
elle est centrale elle est en plein
centre de l'avenue jean médecin c'est à
dire quelque part les champs elysées
niçois on est en plein coeur de nice et
on a été frappée au coeur de cette
église que tous les niçois connaissent
tout le monde a eu un mariage un baptême
un enterrement à l'église notre dame
alors effectivement tout autour de nous
il ya un très important dispositif de
police vous vous l'avez dit le
terroriste islamiste a été arrêtée là
non seulement a été arrêté mais il a été
neutralisé neutraliser et je veux saluer
notre police municipale de nice qui
comme souvent dans ce genre de situation
était parmi les primes aux intervenants
et puis bien sûr aussi la police
nationale et je veux les saluer il a été
neutralisé on sait pas encore il serait
entre la vie et la mort à ce moment même
à aller à l'hôpital
on a trois morts à l'intérieur de cette
église on parle d'une femme de 70 ans
vous me dites comment réagissent les
niçois bien ils réagissent comme vous me
voyez voilà ils sont en colère
on en a marre on en a marre c'est la
deuxième fois qu'on est attaqué ici dans
notre ville c'est la deuxième fois
aucune personne comme terroristes
islamistes attaque dans une église en
france c'est la troisième fois qu'on a
une décapitation dans notre pays
encore une fois on va s'arrêter quand
alors il faut bien sûr tout le monde
connaît c'est qu'on a eue ce terrible
attentat du 14 juillet mais il n'ya pas
que ça il ya aussi tout ce terreau
islamistes on est ici dans une ville où
la majorité des mosquées professe la
doctrine islamiste des frères musulmans
on est dans une ville où il faut bien le
dire et je le dis à votre antenne la
municipalité a installé des mosquées lié
aux islamistes dans des locaux
municipaux
on est dans une ville qui est celle qui
a envoyé le plus de djihadistes on n'a
plus de sens djihadistes qui sont partis
de nice vers l'irak ou la syrie ok
maintenant il faut arrêter tout ça
maintenant il faut agir maintenant il
faut agir